let's go next to john from california
john you're on the air
hi david can you hear me i can hear you
fine it sounds like it sounds like
there's birds where you are
uh yes i'm actually outside on the front
porch is it like a tit mouse or some
kind of parrot what is that
ah no idea it's in the distance
so i'm not really sure yeah no problem
what's going on i'm going to nature
so i had a
oh and we just lost you it sounded like
you were about to say you have a and
then i'm guessing the word was question
but then we just we lost you completely
are you still there
or um i was wondering um so even if it
can even if there is a divide
um wouldn't even once the republicans
still end up voting for whoever the
republican primary is anyway like
because you know i know you said it
still benefits democrats
in in a way but i think when eventually
they would eventually just go republican
because they want to vote republicans
okay so john
we we lost the first half of the
question but i believe i know what it is
which is
even if there is a republican civil war
for now aren't republican voters
eventually just going to vote for
whoever is the nominee is that was that
roughly your question
yep that's correct okay i think they
generally will so like for example right
now you've got
anti-trump republicans
formerly trump republicans and trump
republicans all battling they're
battling over was it an insurrection on
january 6. they're battling over should
we censure people like liz cheney and
kenzie okay fine
eventually aren't they all going to vote
for the nominee the answer is they
mostly will but
when the left isn't really bringing
anything super inspirational to the
table
what we have to hope is that some of
those republicans will just be disgusted
that their wing lost and they'll stay
home i don't think it's likely many of
these republicans would vote for a
democrat in 2024 but if the republican
party continues the infighting hopefully
some of the republican voters will just
get sick of the whole thing and opt to
stay home
okay that makes a lot of sense okay
because yeah okay that makes a lot of
sense thank you david and i just have
just two quick questions i know it's
just a quick answer that you'll have
please both of them um one is to check
the segment or the first one is do you
think there is i know you're not a
virologist but do you think there's a
possible another variant that's out
right now that we don't know of because
i know you said it takes time
to
to for us to figure out one
yeah so this is not my opinion i mean
it's what what virologists say is
they're absolutely are variants out
right now that we don't yet know about
that's just the way it works the
question is do any of them become
concerning and we just don't have an
answer to that yet
okay thank you and the second one is
quickly have you ever thought about
contacting discord about
notification and disruption during calls
because it's i know it's annoying i know
it's annoying for you
i think discord would say we have we
have features to turn that off and just
explain to people how to do it you know
i don't know that discord's gonna do
anything special for me
okay yeah that makes sense all right
thanks a lot all right thanks john
appreciate the call john from california
dropping some serious knowledge on us
uh okay we're gonna take a very quick
break but we're not ending calls okay so
if you would like to speak to me
just hang on because i'm going right
back to the phones in a moment
even if like me you're not vegan and
you're not vegetarian
eating a more plant-based diet is a
really great thing to do for a number of
different reasons and our sponsor just
egg is the delicious plant-based egg you
can use it anywhere you use traditional
eggs because the taste and texture are
identical but just egg plant-based eggs
have the same amount of protein as
traditional eggs i use it all the time
at home you can make fluffy scrambled
eggs you can make omelets you can make
quiche frittata crepes
fried rice you should see my fried rice
recipe you can really use it anywhere in
baking or anywhere you would use
traditional eggs when i first tried just
egg
i was surprised that a plant-based egg
could both taste and cook
just like traditional eggs you can get
it at the grocery store instacart amazon
go try it eating a more plant-based diet
is a great decision i do it and i'm not
vegan or vegetarian and just egg makes
it that much more easy and delicious